hello and welcome to new rock stars my
name is Sam basher and I'm here to bear
good tidings boys and girls I have
finished season two of iron fist and I'm
here to report back it was enjoyable I
actually had a really good time watching
it are their faults and problems oh for
sure every once in a while but the
finale of season two you got me giddy
I actually want the season three now
yeah and as soon as possible please and
thank you why you may ask because this
show had the most epic finale out of all
the Marvel Netflix shows and it
completely changed the game for the Iron
Fist series honestly I fix it everyone
at new rock stars as soon as I was
finished watching it because I had to
make this video
anywho let's take a look at all little
teasers and figure out what that means
for season three if we get one before
the warning of course for Iron Fist
season one and two the defenders Marvel
Netflix shows Marvel Comics and anything
else I can't think up let's begin all
right let's start with the shot that I
want a mural of Colleen wing with the
iron fist igniting her sword with her
Chi so while Danny is off with Ward in
Japan Colleen is taking up the mantle of
the iron fist in New York City we'll get
to Danny's pistols in just a second but
oh boy they're cool
now the idea of calling gaming the iron
fist is a totally original creation for
this show even the white fist that she
uses I do like that it matches her
outfit from the comics which we do get
to see at the end of the series right
there I will say that there are some
versions of the character where Colin
can use her Chi to increase her strength
and durability and she did actually gain
these abilities when she mind melded
with Danny in the comics to gain
knowledge that he obtained in Kunlun
because of course but her wielding her
Chi into an iron fist is so flippin cool
that I flipped out when I was watching
it I was just now notice how she charges
her sword with her Chi giving it that
white light now there are two things to
take away from this one this is actually
something that has happened in the
comics Danny borrowed her sword once and
with his yellow huge fists Jorge dit up
it's pretty cool and to the woman that
she told the story about the pirate
Queen
whoooo she don't kill me there he is
from the comics now it was never
established that Colleen was related to
her but Wu was the first female Iron
Fist she was created by Matt Fraction
and Ed Brubaker and this is just the
first example of the iron fist series on
Netflix tipping its toes into the rich
lore of the character now I can't wait
for a season 3 or at least having
Colleen pop up on other Marvel Netflix
shows because I'm totally excited about
this iron fist protecting Chinatown
let's discuss Danny Rand you might not
be familiar with my feelings on Finn
Jones's portrayal of Danny budge you can
learn more about it by hopping over to
senior comm slash stupid answers my
co-host DJ and I on only stupid answers
rewatched all season one and we are
brutally honest about it it's actually
super fun I even rewatched my descent
into madness and I had a giggle I also
did breakdowns for a flash error
hey this shield super cool any users he
could probably click a link in the
description down below to check it out
so I'm saying now all that said about
Danny he was so much better this season
I truly cared about his journey as a
character and I can't wait to see where
he goes from here but let's focus on
what we do know Danny and ward are in
Japan on a mission to find out who that
spooky Iron Fist corpse belongs to
remember that skin pancake here are two
things we learn one we hear the name
Orson Randall and two danny has those
iron fists by Ock and he's using the
charge up his pistols Wow that's pretty
dope shooting the bullet out of the air
was kind of silly okay but I'm on board
to learn more and here's why Orson
Randall is from the comics and he opens
the door to one of the coolest Iron Fist
storylines of all time now Orson in the
comics is the last person to wield the
iron fist before Danny he was active
during the early 20th century but most
importantly he was the one who wielded
the duel Alliance this pistols they
don't have a name but that trick of
channeling Chi through your guns started
with worsen now we're not sure where
Orson is currently that'll probably be
the big plot point for season 3 at least
for Danny and ward he could teach Danny
a thing or two about what it means to be
an iron fist and where Kunlun could be
hiding we could also get a flashback to
the found footage that we saw in season
one of those troops trying to invade
Kunlun but they were stopped by the iron
fist in full costume but now here's a
question how did Danny get those iron
fists back and how did he channel it
through those pistols could he be slowly
gaining back his ability over time maybe
could he just be meditating it back
mm-hmm not sure or could those guns be
fueling him using residual energy that
Orson left behind it's not really sure
what the rules are for the iron fist
because it's fictional however I do want
to point out that it's been established
in the comics that multiple people can
wield the iron fist at the same time so
I'm pumped to see them deal out justice
all over the globe now one more thing
with the introduction of Orson Randall
this could be hinting like I said to one
of my favorite iron fist storylines
coming to the series the tournament
the heavenly cities we were teased in
season one that Kunlun is one of the
seven cities of heaven so we finally
might be seeing the other six and
they're immortal weapons so cool the
immortal weapons can all wheel chi in
different ways and however the show
runners choose to show that I'm game
this also could lead us to finally
seeing Kunlun after three seasons maybe
even shout out the undying the dragon
we've heard so much about tell I haven't
seen we saw his papers in the dark
that's it maybe I'm getting my hopes up
but of the idea of Kali and Danny being
pulled to Kunlun to fight in a
tournament against other chi enhanced
fighters who you know I'm game
especially if the fight choreography
stays the same or even improves from
this season but what do you all think
did season 2 get you excited enough for
a season 3 or do you rather see these
characters join other Marvel characters
in a Heroes for Hire series maybe a
daughters of the Dragon series featuring
misty and Colleen they're great together
let me know down below I do want to say
if we get a season 3 for Luke Cage we're
gonna need an iron fist to possibly
knock some sense into Luke also some fun
side notes I'm gonna need to learn more
about Mary Walker and her third identity
possibly Bloody Mary possibly ty Ford
Mary who knows also got to see her go up
against Frank Castle or a daredevil
because that would be amazing Alice Eve
killed it all so my boy blind-spot from
the comics popped up in this series he's
just a normal dude let's see Sam chunk
become more than just an awesome helper
of the less fortunate and become the
invisible superhero blind spot please
and thank you but you guys know this
isn't a breakdown but if you want more
iron fist goodies check out sina.com
slash stupid answers for my watch
throughs of season 1 but also check out
everything else senior has to offer they
got some amazing people making great
watch long content for everything from
Netflix to Hulu to YouTube they got it
all but also don't forget to Like
comment share and subscribe for more
breakdowns my name is Sam basher maybe
check out only stupid answers while
you're at it and I'll see you guys next
time